Well,
well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
It was terrible because we were going to start doing stuff like that.
I took such a squirrely dump this morning.
Cool.
I feel like we didn't really get to talk about it.
You don't need to.
Here we go.
Okay.
How does this work?
What are you doing?
Um,
so what we're doing is we're practicing Tantra and uh,
one of the key things that most people don't realize is that orgasm is different
from the traditional release that comes from climax.
Okay.
There we go.
That's what I forgot to do.
Plug in whatever thing needed to be plugged in.
Got It.
And was ranting.
Don't bring it in one loving no bar.
Well,
welcome.
Well go to your mom's house with Tom Circle.
Christina pushes.
It's interesting.
Oh,
that was fun.
Um,
so I don't know if you remember the,
uh,
Hi Melanie.
I'm Scotty with ecstatic hearts.
Tantra.
I was just wanting to share that there are many ways to orgasm actually have to
be having sex.
You can orgasm just from hugging.
Yeah.
Uh,
so we showed you these discussing people a while ago.
Yeah.
Become huggers and,
um,
apparently now they're doing international interviews about it.
It's a stupid,
yeah,
it's so dumb.
It's so horrible.
She's real gummy and I don't really like to shit on people's mouths too much.
You don't know.
I'm like kind of really open minded and stuff about Pete.
Seems like it's,
there's so much more to go after that.
You,
you didn't need to do that,
but go ahead.
No,
it was just a little gummy.
Okay.
But I,
I,
I hate them so much and I'm trying to like what do you hate about them?
I just feel like it's tea.
It's total nonsense.
Like it's,
it's just,
it's horse shit.
It's so,
and it's such like a waste of energy.
Like I feel like they're good people.
They're nice.
You could tell they're nice people.
They're totally nice.
But like feed orphans in Romania or like dig wells in,
in Uganda.
You know what I'm saying?
Like does it,
does it really have to be about coming?
Haven't we?
Haven't we done enough for orgasms in,
in society?
I Dunno.
I mean if they can really teach everyone to come hug,
that's pretty big.
And there's so many more problems in the world.
I mean,
instead of having the traditional trajectory where you kind of get excited and
then climax and then go to sleep,
you're able to have the experience when you keep going and you can start having
multiple experiences.
No,
you mean that the awesome part where you not and you're like,
I'm out.
What's Elena?
And then stop talking at night.
Get outta here.
Don't touch my stuff is the best part right now.
Did you notice that he's shorter than her when they're standing and then they've
made him taller than her and sitting.
He also looked like he put on some weight.
Interesting.
Well,
when you're come hugging,
maybe you're just laying down all the time.
It doesn't,
he look bigger than the no,
I don't think so.
Look at his face there.
Okay.
Hi Melanie.
I'm like the weight weight
maybe.
Yeah,
maybe man.
When you decide to chase,
huskier might come down to here,
but you're in an orgasmic state that can last for a long time.
So then we'll start kind of going down again so you can eat and play and then
bring it back up again.
Okay.
He's so excited.
The dude listening to this,
right?
Let's count.
You could get me calming too.
Oh,
oh.
So
can you get me to come hug me mom
every Sunday for t?
Meanwhile you get me to come one a day that normally my wife has to tug on me
balls to come on me nuts.
Yeah,
I love it.
She's like 20 years old and he's a thousand.
Totally normal.
That camera ready.
He's gross.
He's got a tank from the,
from the commercial point of view,
your point of view,
because that is that ultimate,
you're not doing that for 18 hours.
I mean,
Michelle,
you have no more.
Do you know what's really annoying about these two is that they're always like,
they're always having a smile and being character.
Like we're just always ecstatic.
So great,
great.
That's the thing.
Two different things so you can actually have a full body orgasm.
It's actually more helpful than anything you've done before without the
traditional release and up drain of energy.
It's
confusing.
Um,
content feelings with orgasming you feel the tingling.
You mean like if you hug someone and you're happy about it,
like endorphins or whatever,
you just feel good.
And he's like,
we're orgasming right now.
No,
you're not.
Yeah,
maybe.
I don't think he's having a heart.
I think he's confused.
He's thinking that we're confused.
Yeah.
I think he's quite,
yeah.
Of clearly these people are misguided.
Yeah.
What do you mean,
like tingling?
Yeah,
it feels good.
I gave someone a hug.
I like it.
Yeah.
But we're old or not hug town.
They're rolling sensation.
How is he teaching you to come hug?
Asmec how does it,
how do you teach the calm hub?
That's a very good point.
You can't teach a calm hug either.
You can or you can't count how.
Yeah.
I think it's,
it's a,
it's a little suspect when there's two people in the com hugging,
you know,
business and everyone else is like,
I hug,
I come,
how come I can't make them line up like you guys?
And they're like,
oh,
you need to take our class.
That's true.
If I,
if I met other couples that they've taught to come hug successfully,
then maybe it's always them.
You know?
I wish we could send your parents to go learn to come hug with these two.
Oh my God.
That would be the best.
That would be the best segment ever.
Ever.
On anything.
Your Dad would love it.
Yeah.
Just keep hugging.
I'm going to come after that.
Sounds like fun.
Did you come buddy,
buddy?
I gave you a hug,
but I want to come on you.
God,
I got trained.
I come when I hug now pal
dad.
We practice Tantra,
which helps us to,
oh,
the sexual energy up our bodies.
So the longer we make love,
the more energized we get.
Okay.
Yeah.
I hate that they're from Los Angeles.
These two I'd say this is the,
these are the people that give us a bad rep.
Yeah,
I may.
What?
I mean
chicken be going to sleep at 10 and by dawn we're like,
yeah,
I can,
the flavor you have to be getting,
and he urges me to keep going.
I then I just keep getting more energized every time.
Oh,
I'll be going.
Sure.
How about that rob?
Posto right.
We're talking about when they are not actually fucking baby.
No,
they're talking about fucking to,
Oh,
now there are times when the actual fucks.
Yes.
Well,
uh,
I don't like her voice.
She talks like the dumb girl that you do the impression of.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I'm at [inaudible] House.
How bout like,
we should keep data?
Um,
uh,
ah,
and then I felt energized after was like,
I,
yeah,
like don't you,
you do know what you sound like when you talk.
Right?
Like she's no awareness then she sounds totally ridiculous.
Yeah.
Oh,
you've never bust out laughing.
Ha
laughing.
Oh yeah.
We,
the truth is we all have our emotions.
It love making,
we laugh.
Look at
ourselves.
We cry.
Where's that drive plus question though?
I think that's the question that everybody's thinking about is that her vagina
will dry out from so much of that meeting.
Can you imagine if we had 18 hours sessions?
No,
I can't.
I know you said like at night and then by fucking sunrise,
it's like where you want to fuck for nine hours.
You don't got no kids.
No.
You know what I'm saying?
They ain't got no time.
Even if you,
let's say you didn't,
do you want to fuck for a half a day?
Oh,
I got stuff to do that.
Well,
here's the thing is I want to do that Trish and Bob,
Bobby,
uh,
we get our free gone and then it's straight to the,
the routine we got to flipping out to catch up on and we've got the Shahs of
sunset there shows to watch.
We've got and finish Ozar,
Ozar.
You know what I mean?
Like real married couples.
You gotta you gotta fuck and then do the stuff married couples do.
Yeah.
You can't just fuck,
fuck,
fuck all the time.
It's silly.
No,
there's other parts to American college.
You know what I'm saying?
You guys gotta go downstairs,
get your snack,
get give the dogs treats.
Yup.
You know what I mean?
There's all these things
I do.
I feel you,
in order to do this kind of thing,
you have to be connected with your emotions and your feelings and your channel
so that you can feel the energy moving through your body.
And that's what makes it kind of a spiritual practice as well as just the
orgasmic one.
Very loud making all the time.
And it totally wasn't orgasmic experience as well.
All right.
Fuck all blah blah.
I feel like studio London might think the studio Los Angeles is retarded.
I think they're right.
Yeah,
I agree with studio London on this one.
Yeah.
This is embarrassing.
Sorry.
Angelenos and I'm,
I'm,
I'm apologizing piles.
Ah,
you're talk like La.
I hate,
I hate when la girls talk like that.
It's so embarrassing.
What time are they doing this show?
I'll xy.
I'll la Ha's off.
I was all like,
you don't necessarily have to be together to make this work because this is an
energy exchange.
You thinking you can be in separate rooms and do this.
Yeah.
Um,
so first of all,
we can feel each other.
Even when we're apart,
we can out of them all by ourselves just through breathing and like feeling,
um,
orgasm with God.
Okay.
I'm sure your mom would like that part,
right?
Yeah,
that'd be the best part my mind for sure.
Like religious people,
just like you learn about face right here.
Studio London,
guys face.
Did you just say you're going to come with God?
Yeah,
fortunately this is the end of the clip that we have.
I would love to hear the followup to that.
Ahca calm with God.
Like,
I'm sorry,
what did you just say?
Okay,
Sweetie.
Super disrespectful.
Yeah,
very calm with God.
buddy.
Your mom and I a me man with God.
Yeah.
Anyway,
it's so gross.
What would your dad would talk to you about his come hugs all the time,
but if he could do it,
maybe.
I don't know.
He,
he was never that
guy.
I know some guys,
you know,
their dads would get
little too familiar.
A little personal with that stuff.
Thank God he wasn't like that.
He was,
I mean he's like the obviously with bathroom stuff,
but now it's sex stuff.
Thank God.
And it's real traumatizing as a child here.
That what makes it difficult?
I mean,
I've proud of him for like full Bush,
right?
Like big cans.
Right.
But he doesn't act like no details.
I don't want to discuss to,
I've never detailed God.
It's borderline incestuous.
When your parents tell you about their sex lives or what turns them on,
it's like,
I don't,
you're never supposed to know that stuff.
One time we were,
we were on like a little weekend trip that nasty.
And there was a couple they had,
they were new labor each other's second marriage and they each had their own
kids.
And the dad,
uh,
I was talking to,
his son was 15,
and he had on some high school sweatshirt with football on it.
So he started talking about football and he was like,
yeah.
I was like,
he's a big kid.
And he was like,
yeah,
you know,
he plays whatever position and blah,
blah,
blah.
And then I'm sitting there talking to him.
I remember this guy now and he goes,
uh,
he was like,
you know,
I told him,
man,
just get all of the posts that you can,
you know,
and was like,
what?
And he's like,
I told him,
you know,
there's this,
you got to get all the posts you can right now.
Yeah.
I was looking at him like,
dude,
do you really think your fucking son once you to talk to him about all the pussy
he can get?
No.
No kid wants to hear that from his dad.
You know,
let his uncle say that if,
if it's,
if someone has too,
but like,
yeah,
here's the,
I have to fucking,
it's weird.
Yeah,
It's wrong.
I don't even like hearing sex jokes like from like parents shouldn't be telling
sex jokes.
Somebody else's.
It's nasty as hell.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
it's wrong.
It's totally,
could you imagine saying something to Lj?
Thank you.
Getting laid kid and like,
Eh,
no,
this is so wrong.
That whole thing down for like,
I'll talk like that crazy somebody else,
but not my own kid.
It's wrong.
Yeah.
I looked at the guy,
he was like,
right.
And I remember,
I was like,
ah,
yeah,
no,
good as much as you can.
And you can tell the kid was like,
hmm.
He knew.
He knew he was a cute boy.
He's a good boy.
But he knew.
He knew that like,
uh,
I didn't do this.
Yeah.
Be Normal.
You just want them to be normal.
You folks just don't be gross.
Don't be,
when I was also a new guy,
right.
I met them at this thing and here his dad's talking about some streaming pussy
in front of them.
It's strange.
It's weird.
It's weird way to wait to do it.
Dad,
here's a fingernail question.
No,
I'm,
somebody wrote in there,
what if you're dating someone for like six months and they're like,
hey,
I need to tell you,
I used to have 12 inch fingernails,
obviously a deal breaker.
When is the right time to tell us when you used to be a fucking maniac,
I think that you weighed on that.
You wait,
you sit on that knowledge.
But the fact that they used to be and now they're reformed.
Yeah,
it's fine.
Right.
But you still want to give that away early.
He told Yo wait til the I love you's have been exchanged.
Yeah.
And there's like,
if you have like a weird thing that you're even,
that you're into now.
I don't,
I'm not an advocate of sharing that upfront.
You just kinda no,
I'm saying like don't,
you don't have to introduce like a pissing my mouth.
I'd love it.
You know,
like that's not a date.
One thing to introduce,
not a day one,
but soonish because why?
Well,
because that way you weed out the ones that aren't going to do it.
You get it.
You knock it out early.
Yeah.
Not too early because it's not your sole identity.
So since this is not your identity,
you can,
I mean,
if you're like all I do is drink piss and that's what I live by it.
Yeah.
Then you need to,
but if you're like,
that's kind of my thing.
You don't need to bring that up on the third day.
Do you Kinda want that?
You want the girl to like you,
like you kind of want to rope her random,
manipulate her a little bit more emotional named Thomas sacred like,
yeah.
Tava hobbyists.
I hop out be like,
well you remember the other day when you're going to the bathroom and she's
like,
yeah,
I really wish you would have gone hi,
how much?
She's like,
wait what?
And then you're like,
well already but does it fit to fucking Fiji so I guess you're going to have to
piss in my mouth over there.
You're kind of manipulating the situation a little bit to me it sounds like.
Yeah,
that's what I'm suggesting.
Roping her in and then like eat what does free trip,
right?
Then you got a penis in my mouth.
Yeah,
exactly.
If you want to get away with something that weird,
you've got to manipulate a little bit.
That's what I would,
that's what a doctor would tell you to do.
It's interesting or just be super rich like that also gives me an error status
like that guy like garage in hammocks or whatever.
Shit.
Through the Hammock in my mouth.
Apparently that's all you need is a few mil.
And women are like,
okay.
I mean other than that being disgusting that that's fine because he was like,
I'll give you a hundred bucks a shit in my mouth.
And they were like,
all right.
Even Steven.
Yeah.
Even Steve It,
there's no problem with that.
No,
I like it.
I like the,
uh,
I like an honest exchange.
Yeah.
You know,
like I,
we talked about this on the live show a little bit.
[inaudible] was Hugh Hefner's death.
I don't,
I don't think he was some great fucking pioneer.
I think he was kind of a creeper and uh,
he had a man should full of broken,
broken girls who he,
you know,
he let live there for free,
but he didn't pay them.
He had like a weekly stipend and then it was a [inaudible] your movie where the,
yeah.
And I silk pajamas and then,
uh,
he butt fucked a lot of them,
but sexton cause he didn't want anyone pregnant.
It's true.
Breed breed.
Holly.
Holly Madison's book.
Fucking Huh?
Yes.
Discuss.
I can.
Such a power move.
Like I know some people,
some people are certainly is.
It certainly is.
I know women that are,
you know,
very much into it for the physical sense.
I like that.
That's for them as euphoria.
Right.
Um,
and there's obviously people who that's their sexual turn on,
but in and of itself,
like if you strip,
let's say someone's preferences to that away,
that's an aggressive move.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a dominant mood strike.
I'm going to fuck you and your ass.
Gosh,
it's so great.
Yeah.
Your butt hole is very sensitive and,
and put it comes down.
My God,
you guys just show disgusting.
Yeah.
It's poop.
Poop comes out of credit in that pervert.
He's like,
oh,
the big sexual revolution.
Yeah,
but it is still according to like a white guy's preference.
Fucking though only blondes.
It was one type of woman that he liked.
It was like,
you know,
the cookie cutter,
big tits,
Pam Anderson,
if you had little hungry tits,
forget it.
He had a big ass forget it was like his way.
And I like Larry Flynt way better than that.
We talked about pedaling Larry Flint just because it's honest.
He was like,
put that fucking candle holder in your place,
right?
You want $100?
Yeah,
spread it.
Great.
You put your hand further up there and there's no horse shit.
Mystique of the mansion and living with Hefner.
And he was a real,
when it was just like,
look,
I'm a pig,
he's a pig.
PERV and it's an even exchange.
Here's some cash spread your beef.
And there was no convoluted thing of like how many girlfriends does a guy have
on a bus?
My goal wheelchair real quick.
Well and he said to like,
well Holly said in her book that they,
he would be like,
all right,
you too make out.
And then they'd make out and he,
you know,
jerk it.
That's cool.
And then they'd throw like the new girl at him so that they were off the hook
for the night.
My you deal with him?
Yeah.
How about though you got half tonight and she's like,
oh,
it was cool.
It kept fucking my butt though.
Yeah,
that's what he does.
What he does.
Not Grad.
He's 92 today.
It's exciting and I like your great,
great grandpa
and I and I and last night with the live show and people were like,
yeah,
it's great exposure.
Okay,
well you think about it.
Let's think about the stars that really came out of playboy.
You had your Pamela Anderson,
that's the anomaly.
I think she,
she was apparently Anderson as a genuine,
like an icon.
She's Canadian but,
but became an American icon.
Maybe Jenny McCarthy.
She was famous before she did it.
She was,
you know,
but other than that,
I mean,
who's,
who's really stuck home and electro appointment yet,
but she was also fucking prints and yeah,
no,
she was just a chicken or the egg.
Where you a whole before,
you know?
I don't know.
I don't,
I just,
when he died I was like,
it was funny too,
Holly was saying that the mansion was all run down and shit too.
She's like,
it's not nice that she has oldest,
you know,
they put in bunk beds and the playmates rooms.
Why you would give up on keeping it like super nice.
Cause it's expensive.
I'm sure he's got the money.
Yeah.
Read the grotto and they're like,
Hey,
do you want new carpets?
And everyone?
He's like,
how am I says um,
it's $3,000 that's a lot of ammonium
leave the old carpet.
Okay.
Half.
I don't think,
I don't think there's playboys cellar box.
Somebody in the Bot right now.
Okay.
We'll get the new girl down here immediately.
But don't you imagine that once the Internet started that who the heck is even
looking at playboy?
Oh,
of course.
When you can see everything.
Yeah.
Like no one's buying that shit for the last 20 years.
I mean,
when I was a kid,
obviously there's no internet and the magazine was just tits.
That's the one thing that was kind of Nice.
Right?
Cause you were excited by that.
You're excited by seeing some Bush,
right?
You're like,
oh,
and just like a beautiful body.
Yeah,
man,
that's,
I'm going to jerk off to this right now.
And then the internet ruined.
Desensitized.
You're completely,
yeah,
we were like a naked body.
So what can I do?
Can I,
can we stab it?
Can we put it in a toilet bowl?
Why didn't she crying more?
And she gagging,
choking.
I put my fist down or oh it's gotta be
at gotta get hard on with that.
Isn't that funny?
It's so funny.
It's really crazy man.
Yeah.
I guess my only beef too is like,
I always want to see women exploiting other women.
Making the money,
make the money.
If you're going to exploit the women,
at least give them the fucking,
the money.
Dickhead.
Make that money.
Come on slides,
make your own stuff.
You know,
cause it all boils down to the finances.
Dude.
He's got the power.
They don't have the power sucks.
I think these days I'm not,
I mean I don't know the specifics,
the names and all that.
Typically the things,
but there's definitely some women,
I think doing some producing some kind of plan.
And I'm,
listen,
there's two sides to this debate.
And,
and,
and when women's world,
there are girls who find being naked,
very empowering and very awesome.
And then there are other women that just are like,
it's not for me,
it's just not for me personally.
But I understand why some women think it's a great thing to do.
It feels good to them.
Want,
feel powerful,
then you know more and more power to you.
But sure.
I think that guys,
if a creeper,
yeah,
all it is.
Hell,
he's super old.
How old was he when he died?
It was like over 90 damn good in here.
I would think it's even grosser.
Just asleep next to him.
He'd be like,
these are all just old smelling and your body's just,
you know,
just falling apart.
Literally decaying.
Yeah.
And like,
you know,
the muscle has gone and your face and you know,
like he probably,
he was like,
ah,
and be like,
you all right.
He's a,
that's what it sounds like when I breathe.
They're like,
oh my God,
I'm going to sleep next to you.
Yeah.
But that's why his up.
Fuck you in the morning.
I gotta take my shot and I'll fuck you in the button in the morning.
Okay.
That's why the house was so damn old.
You know how old people's houses look like them?
They start to smell and you're like,
that's broken.
And they're like,
that's what I'm saying.
Like somebody else should have been like,
I'm going to run this,
keep this house pristine.
His daughter took over the dealings of the magazine and the pro waste money on
his house.
He's a old piece of shit.
It's going to die and then we're going to kick out all these sluts and then I'm
going to take over Saudi.
Think what you think of the house is.
I think the house is like the property's worth a lot.
The house is probably,
I think of it,
the house was probably dog shit,
but then it's like what's the house worth in terms of its significance?
In other words,
you know the historical value of it being the playboy mansion,
all the aids that's been transferred in that house.
All the herpes and gonorrhea that had been transmitted.
The grotto.
Yeah.
Can you think of anything?
Grocer
girls on the road,
I'll blah,
blah,
fuck from at,
I mean Larry Flint.
I feel like it was just straight forward and,
and you know,
didn't,
yeah.
Send the girls and you know that girls can't say no.
No one's saying no.
Why couldn't it just be an even?
People said no over the years.
And I was definitely the day you found your shit right up.
Yeah.
You should be out of here,
which is terrible.
Like that's a Harem then you're,
you're keeping women hostage.
You're not,
uh,
it's not an,
it's not a fair exchange.
No.
You know,
this ongoing hostage situation.
Yeah.
If you don't do it,
then you're homeless.
It's fucking terrible.
Unreal.
And people think he's a big hero,
this fucking asshole.
I mean,
I get,
look,
he's a great entrepreneur.
He built an empire.
Everyone respects that in this country.
But gaberdine by the way,
how do you feel about this or shower farts?
The safest.
Huh?
Um,
someone said it before in the shower.
He never had the fear that Brown is running down.
You know,
it feels like a little extra.
You're close enough to the toilet or you can just stop it down.
So it's the trouble of Brown yourself is now removed is a stupid one question.
I know,
but I don't understand why we're doing it.
It's just,
it's in my emails and just brought it up.
Now I shower.
Fart is not this.
I know what the thinking is that if I fart in the shower,
then there's a brown comes down.
I can just put it through the drain.
That's silly.
The safest far the only safe farts or on the toilet.
Everybody knows this.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's the safest place you can fart.
It's true.
Why would you just don't go just do it on the toilet.
Don't go in the shower yet.
Yeah.
But if you have one in the shower,
they're saying,
do you let it out?
Of course.
Yeah.
That's,
that's the,
that's the whole reason you live.
You take the gamble on a far like that.
You're talking about gambling.
Um,
here's a colonoscopy.
Before I tried to play it at the live show,
but it's really a studio piece.
I think this is a lady Postcoloniali a piece.
She really gave me a proper,
oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh.
That's like old school.
So you know,
no girl,
I don't know.
Oh my God.
That's classic when you Omg,
Omg and she looks like the Moose Suit Lady,
which is neat too.
You think she does?
That's not very nice
lady.
After she had a call and asking me for
what I'm trying to figure out,
is this somebody who did the Oh,
um,
oh my gosh.
For the show or is that just a coincidence?
In other words,
yeah.
Michelle,
I think it might.
Maybe the lady recording.
I'm saying,
Oh,
maybe.
And she goes,
no,
no.
The lady that recorded said it.
Oh,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
I guess it's,
you know,
it's fun thing to do.
Yeah.
She's got that smoker's laugh.
Yeah,
she does.
She does cheese,
moose soup on the regular,
uh,
a Siamese twin question.
Is this good?
I was wondering if Simon,
he's conjoined twin murders,
if somewhere was the other twin vehemently process protesting and trying to stop
the murder.
How has the guilty twins sent to jail?
Assuming they can't be separated?
That's an interesting question.
So to be clear,
they're saying conjoined twins.
One of them is like,
I'm going to kill this person either.
I was like,
you can't fucking do that.
Right.
What do you do at that point?
As far as punishment,
but then that they both have to go to prison.
Well,
how is that fair to the one who's like,
I objected.
It's not fair.
Life's not fair.
They were born conjoined twins.
Their whole existence isn't fair.
I don't know.
I think they would have a really strong case to keep the,
the,
the guilty one free.
Here's solution ankle bracelet on the guilty one so that the,
the good one can lead their life and then,
but no,
here's what does the court will say,
you should've called the police.
Why didn't she got to go further than that?
That he's going to be like,
I tried and then he fucking threw the phone down and I was,
I was pulling his arm away and he was insisting on,
you know,
you're the murder champion.
You tell me what happened.
I'm talking about the ramifications,
not the actual murder itself,
but you've seen enough sentencing shows and murder shows you word the court's
lien.
I don't know.
I think that I've never heard a case like this.
This is what would be so exciting about it,
is that it would be a whole new field,
a whole new arena within crimes and punishment.
Let me terrible,
I imagine they put the bad one in prison and then the good one just gets to like
watch TV and eat real food in the,
maybe like,
like they divide the cell in half.
And I'm like,
no,
this has to go for a walk.
That person,
those people that are conjoined are either free or they're locked up now.
I know.
You'd be really,
I mean,
it's completely unfair to the other person in either scenario.
It's fucked up,
man.
The whole thing is fucked up.
Yeah.
Very fucked up.
It's not cool.
I hate to be a conjoined twin.
That's gotta be the worst,
by the way.
We were talking about just what do you,
how do you feel about this?
Um,
did you read any of the Harvey Weinstein stuff?
Yeah,
I mean,
I,
uh,
I did so great.
It's so funny because people that don't know
introduce you,
that is Harvey Weinstein founded a Miramax,
the film production,
the playboy,
the film industry,
and a Miramax eventually sold to Disney.
And then,
um,
he started,
he founded the Weinstein company with his brother and their,
you know,
their big time,
Hollywood producers.
What they are,
they make movies.
There are movie producers.
They,
you know,
his early stuff was like,
he,
he did all of Quentin Tarantino stuff.
So he did pulp fiction.
He's done the whole Tarantino catalog.
He did clerks.
He's done a bunch of Matt Damon movies.
I mean,
there,
he's big time.
So you look at Harvey Weinstein and
the Weinstein Company,
you see that every time.
Every movie,
right?
Yeah.
So it used to be Miramax,
which was his,
um,
let's see.
Let me just to give you,
I mean,
I want to give you like a full,
a full,
you know,
uh,
idea of
what'd you use to get those fart?
Mike's installed,
you know,
is that just a pipe dream?
You have to like a double side.
His,
his,
um,
imtp.
Yeah,
it's not even like one list of things.
It is.
It's just every,
every movie this guy did.
It's so many movies,
man.
Um,
let's,
I'm trying to look for like the,
the huge wow Mandela thing here.
Oh,
the Butler,
I think that won an Oscar.
Um,
let's see.
Uh,
Django unchained silver linings playbook.
Oh,
that was that one.
Good.
One big.
And you know me,
I love that show.
I miss her and she rest in peace,
but yeah.
Scream all good things.
The fighter,
the king's speech,
I think that won an Oscar,
or at least the actor one.
Um,
all right,
well,
you get the point.
It's dozens and literally dozens and hundreds of movies is what he's produced.
Hundreds of movies.
Um,
anyways,
so it just came out that he,
uh,
has been sexually harassing.
I guess it's like a big open Hollywood secret.
He's been sexually harassing,
harassing women for years.
Everyone from interns to actresses to coworkers,
uh,
all these people,
he's had eight settlements.
Um,
yeah.
Then he released the weirdest statement where he was like,
I didn't behave the way I should have.
I'm working on that.
Um,
and uh,
now I'm going to go after the NRA like a total,
no,
he took time off.
Don't know.
Is this before the NRA?
He takes time off right now and now he just distracting.
But with the NRA stuff,
that's total bullshit.
Nonsensical thing to do.
It's saying,
don't be mad like you're mad at me for doing this thing,
but guess what I'm going to do?
I'm going to do something that you can get behind.
I'm going to go after the NRA fucking absolute nonsense.
And if you fall,
you know he wants you to fall for that.
Like,
well,
he's going to go out.
He's going to go after these gun lobbyists.
It's too just to get you to not think about smoking mirrors.
Guys.
After that was released,
more women came forward and then a couple where it wasn't like,
like where he cornered someone jerked off in a plant,
in a restaurant and then,
and then a couple others and then the board of directors at that company fired
him because it finally went public.
Yeah,
they,
of course everybody knew.
They knew no one gave a shit until it was made public.
And then of course,
be held accountable.
But anyway,
I mean,
if you're going to get into the movie producing business,
there's no way you get into it in front of people.
Well,
especially if you're a a,
you know,
he's not an attractive guy.
He's kind of nebbishy looking old.
Nebbishy I'm attractive.
That's why you become a big movie producer.
So you can be like,
look,
do you want a part in this movie?
You got to suck my stuff.
I have come all over my face and now you have a part in a movie.
Right?
But,
but now here's the thing.
I honestly think that's an even exchange,
which is which one,
which is,
hey,
if you suck my stuff,
you get to be a star in my movie.
And then the girl that,
yeah,
that's totally fine.
Of course,
because this is what this is fucking show business is the most corrupt and
stupid thing in the,
in the world.
Uh,
and that,
that's just how it is.
Are you saying he was on sleep bill each other every day in this business for
advantage of course.
No,
no,
but I,
I feel like it's at least a more honest way of dealing with shit.
Like in our business,
everything else is such bullshit.
Like sometimes I kind of wish someone had been like,
look,
do you fucking,
you want this deal?
I'd be like,
yeah,
we don't have to do for it.
And you just gotta I got drop off in this plant and you got to watch like,
okay,
that's it.
And then we're straight though.
Everything's like on on level.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a way more honest way of doing things.
I know it doesn't take as long to if somebody would offer.
Yeah,
it's a struggle all these years.
That's what I'm saying.
Get a special,
that's why I wasn't fucking took me so long to cook.
I was like,
who's,
I just show me the Dick.
I know who,
who are Netflix?
Did you know who was big?
It can go,
yeah,
right here.
I would have done it ages ago instead.
This a clean system of,
you know,
normal deals and this and that.
I,
yeah,
didn't Sam,
maybe you,
but you wouldn't say no.
Would you know,
I would've been like,
yeah,
do it.
But
there's this guy,
he said he's going to make us special for me.
Look Great.
And you'd be like,
he's got a check off like on me or telling me like,
yeah,
do it.
But who is it?
Is it like a big producer?
Like a big producer?
Yeah,
yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
But then,
then you're out.
Then the deal is like,
again,
it's the Larry Flynt School of business where it's like,
it's a,
it's a contract.
Look,
I went to law school for two weeks.
Here's what I learned to contract is an exchange of something for something
else.
Right.
Very cut and dry.
You give the guy a hand job,
you get a part in the movie.
It's so fucking clean.
I can't that happen more.
I am sure it does to,
I mean,
I feel like a part in a movie.
What,
who do I have to,
I know,
right?
What she was attracted to me,
I would have done it.
He's not,
he's in the,
he's in the pretty girls.
How about like 41 year old moms even mushy.
Perps for sure.
Yeah,
for sure.
And I love how you know the look,
Hollywood has never been known for being a non corrupt horse shit business.
You know,
like actresses are like,
I can't believe it.
He invited me to his hotel room.
Why did you go to his hotel room a lot?
Like,
you know what I mean?
You think that was where the business deal happens?
Come on up.
Yeah,
I'll go there.
I actually,
Judd came out and she said that it was a weird,
you know,
she goes,
I went to the hotel to meet him and then like come up to go up to the suite and
he was like,
she was like,
okay.
And then he was in his robe.
It's like she had to bullshit to get out of there before we get she's,
and she's a legit talent.
She doesn't need to suck his Dick Dick.
No,
of course not.
No.
But yeah,
I mean,
he's a,
he's out.
He's out now.
And there's so many other dudes doing that and stuff.
Oh yeah.
A lot of guys do that.
A lot of guys forcing their dick and balls on you.
That's the thing.
The world is always going to be full of creepers.
I mean,
I hope to some extent we can wait him out by shaming them like we are now in a
position of power is scary though.
It's all,
they're always going to be dudes that are powerful or going to,
some of them are going to be used that I know it's too bad creepers.
So a lot of people out there know,
um,
refer to me and understand that I'm the hat comic.
But then yesterday someone decided to be a swagger Jagger and a cracker jack or
did you come up with that and no,
but I you can see that,
um,
it looks so much better on me.
You were clowning me and you were just like,
oh,
I can't believe you're wearing crazy hats.
And then all of a sudden now the swagger jacker in charge.
So if my bear hat called this style soccer,
yeah.
And Josh gave this to you last night at the Pod,
but the problem is your head is too big.
Let's show them what it looks like.
It looks so good on me.
See,
first I was looking at me.
Look how good I look and look at it.
It looks like a baby hat.
Looks like a toddler hat.
Yeah,
no,
it's looks terrible.
Yeah.
So this was his grandfather's hat.
Yeah,
I was bear Bryant.
but I mean like,
it fits my persona.
And then you're like,
what about me?
Thank you.
The hat person now.
Oh,
I thought you were ragging on that person.
You're like,
ah,
I'll,
I'll do it.
I'll be the hat.
Not that it's that,
that hat looks terrible on you.
Okay.
This hallux songs better look how much better would the cargo on it.
That looks good on you though,
on the Taco hat guy.
You don't know who gave us.
To me,
it was either given to me by the Taco people in Houston that came and gave us a
bunch of Tacos,
or I feel like maybe Richard Franco,
the,
uh,
competitive eater gave it to me.
Maybe I'm confused.
But James Franco,
James Franco,
the actor.
Yeah,
he gave it to me.
I just feel like baseball caps look good on you.
Yeah,
but advanced hats like the one I'm wearing.
don't look good on you.
This is like a varsity level hat and that's for you.
Yeah.
I don't wear hats,
but this one I will because look how nice it looks,
but look how good I look in the roll tide.
You're going to say that I don't,
I don't subscribe to that.
I don't.
I don't say that.
The hat you're wearing,
this is not an Alabama football team hat.
That's 100% in Alabama football team at human to show you.
Okay.
It's a called a fedora hat and you don't understand anything.
This is worn by Justin Timberlake.
He likes these hats.
They roll tide hat.
Okay.
I don't,
you mean that the only people that wear these or roll tide people?
Yes.
Oh my God.
I look like that old man or this all guy.
That's the same guy.
That's his hat.
And you,
oh my God.
The famous head coach,
former head coach of the Alabama Crimson tide.
See Alabama on it.
See,
so he made this popular,
this style 100%.
I Wa he's got good taste and so do I.
Okay,
so now we say it rolled the died.
No nuts.
No rolling tides.
There you go.
Jesus.
Unbelievable.
How old is that guy?
Well,
he's very dead but I don't know.
It was,
yeah,
so he started it and I'm carrying the tradition.
You're carrying it on.
Yeah.
You're the person.
The one qualified.
I definitely looked great in his hat.
You definitely do actually fits you well.
Yeah.
Cause I'm cool Justin Timberlake too.
You're not cool.
I'm so much cooler than you.
What are you looking at?
Who's texting you?
Sexting is a big group
text going on right now about the bet.
And um,
apparently Arie and his podcast said he like,
I guess he had said something about not doing some poses so that,
you know,
Joe called him out and said,
are you not doing all the poses?
Area was very defensive.
Burt's real excited that his,
uh,
sitting heart rate is resting heart rate is 47.
Um,
but anyways,
I um,
but he also takes like blood pressure medication which lowers your heart rate.
So he doesn't even,
she's just so he's taking stuff to to alter it,
isn't it?
Yeah.
And then he's like,
well it's really low.
Well,
delusional,
you're manipulating it.
Didn't you didn't think about that.
What's your resting heart rate d now it's actually lower.
Yeah,
but you've always had like no pulse.
My resting heart rate is so low that they,
my physician sent me to a cardiologist.
The cardiologist sent me to Cedars Imaging Institute and they were like,
that's,
you know,
I even used to talk about it in my act and they were like,
so did you use to run marathons or something?
Cause sure.
My,
my resting heart rate usually between 36 and 44.
So that's like,
you either have like something wrong or you have like a really strong heart,
right?
Like that's like elite.
Their hearts don't have to work as much.
I've heard your heart.
I put my head on your chest.
Du,
Du.
It's practically dead.
Well,
I went away for 10 years.
I had every test run.
I mean like I think $30,000 worth of tests done.
This is a few years ago and at the end with like with,
after all,
it's multiple days of going,
injecting me with things have me run on treadmills,
all that stuff.
They're like,
oh,
it's got a strong heart.
I was like,
that's the conclusion and be like,
yeah,
okay.
That was it.
I hope so.
I hope it is that you just have a superior,
I mean I,
I did the test you've gone to where they do like the ultrasound and you can see
it and cedars imaging institute,
like it was a full like multi day,
10 years ago.
No,
I went more recently.
He did?
Yeah.
Okay.
I also had the um,
the cardiac calcium test done where they score basically.
It's like a,
basically like a plaque test.
10 to zero to a hundred.
Yeah,
the zero.
That's a great gun.
I don't want to lose you yet.
I'm not going anywhere.
What I do?
Hey Man,
I'll be right here,
you know?
Yeah,
there you go.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Um,
this is always adorable.
The kids say the darndest things,
you know,
do points in the 20s and near 30 degrees across central Mississippi.
Well,
hey there,
what's going on with Zane?
Doesn't know.
Sure.
Wait,
someone's kid,
but check this out.
This is fine.
Fantastic.
Well,
we've got a little bit of a interesting things going on right now.
I want to point out the weather right now.
Yeah.
There are parts everywhere.
I like that kid.
Yeah.
It was that our son.
I wish that I would,
I wish I had been watching the news when that happened.
That would make my day 100%.
I mean,
to watch that kid,
what's the ratings go through the roof and they hire that kid to do it through
the news parts everywhere and there's tutes and it's going to rain today.
What could be better news on it?
I've loved that.
Yeah.
I wish that would do that too.
To everywhere.
Fantastic.
Yeah.
No,
I love it.
What's the deal with weathermen anyways?
I mean would,
do we even need them anymore,
you know,
guys,
what's the,
why are the two or too,
that's why,
um,
do you remember a while back we did the,
uh,
the Juggalo episode?
Yes.
What do you remember about it?
Well,
the fans are very unique.
Um,
they tend to attract,
they tried a lot of people.
It's a,
it's a very accepting community.
It's like a catchall community and there's a little bit of mental illness in
that community.
I'd say some drug use,
but I think overall it's a positive theme.
Like the whole thing is like being accepting.
Yeah.
They were pretty accepting.
Um,
it was like a nice theme.
There was a lot of like tattoos,
right?
Face painting and yeah.
A lot of face painting as part of the culture.
I think a high sugar diet seems to be part of culture too.
A lot of car bloating.
Yeah.
I mean that's just,
I didn't see any verification other than
faces,
but um,
it felt like that was kind of a theme.
You know,
sugar,
sugar seemed like it was a theme to me.
I Dunno if I'm wrong,
it really felt very much like that.
Um,
so anyways,
we uh,
you know the,
the Juggalos follow the uh,
ICP bro,
insane clown posse.
Right.
Um,
there was a few people that wrote in and told us that they were,
they used to be Juggalos are they used to follow ICP and told us a little bit
about,
you know,
what you were talking about that it was accepting it was something to do as a
place to go.
They're very successful.
They,
they've got a lot of ICP.
Yeah.
Excuse me.
I think there was some discussion of like buying an island or something and
having a central location for like all the Juggalos to meet and you know,
like,
like Margaritaville kind of thing like with Jimmy Buffet.
Right.
So all the fans can be together cause they had,
when they have their big get togethers it is huge turnout.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Huge.
Uh,
okay.
That guy's great.
This is from that movie.
I'm a fucking nice person.
I could cook like a motherfucker who makes some fucking straight up fucking
grove.
Okay.
Chicken fried steak,
chicken,
Collard Greens.
Fuck ain't mashed potatoes.
All that fucking good as sausage gravy,
biscuits.
Fucking everything.
Me,
I cook like a motherfucker.
I want to find a skinny ass little bitch.
I ain't make her fat.
That'd be lose weight together.
I have a bond.
There you go.
Yeah,
that I missed that one.
That was really funny.
That was really fun.
And the juggle,
there's that documentary,
but this was sent to us and it said that this is a Juggalo [inaudible]
he's,
he gives you a while.
He introduces that,
that he wrote a song and then he wants to free saw his song just for the public,
you know.
Okay.
So this is a guy.
This is an original work.
Oh cool.
Um,
okay.
Here we go.
I have another beat down for you.
I tried to practice talk just in my own song,
just mine production of song.
Same one thing about the car building,
I'll sing it.
No,
that I think mistake number one is if you're going to sing a song,
you may want to go on a nice sound proofed environment or like a somewhat sounds
like even guys indoors right
now with the,
you can hear the traffic driving by,
right?
Right.
Like not in front of the freeway.
Off Ramp and a parking lot somewhere.
Right.
Good points.
Just sit in your car.
Even with the windows up.
Very true.
So there's sound problems.
Number one,
that is a fair assessment,
but now you got to give at least give him a chance to do the song.
Of course.
Yes.
Okay,
here we go.
Here's the song.
Yes sir.
She's worth the machines.
Was Dan.
I got a gun and got again.
Yeah,
I've got a gun terminating her gun.
machines.
But then machines worth [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] g six g 100% she's
16 machines with thin or shootings with thin.
It's not,
I actually,
I don't think it's bad.
I cut him off.
Charles Drake,
my rough,
trying to make my rough,
trying to talk to some with the flow,
trying to practice some are full machines with two machines.
Was Jean with them?
My own the street.
I don't care if the hitters fr the haters.
No.
Hey machines worth it.
Was that a Bush I could leave cause that he pushed pressed aside.
I heard like cause it felt like right then he like brush up against something.
Right.
What was that?
And there is a wrestling of some sort of,
yeah,
sure.
I'll talk to some are full machines with two machines.
Was gene where they stepped on something street?
I don't care.
But the hitters fr the haters.
Monash loud,
no change with it.
Now change then
wrapping on the song shoes worth then walking down the streets,
walking down the stretch,
walking down the street.
Here's a good thing so far he is,
he says align repeats that line.
Yeah.
That's called a song.
Come and then finds an online repeats that line and then it goes back to that.
Okay.
Yeah.
But that's what,
that's what a song is.
And is that what a song is?
Yeah.
They just repeat the same crap over and over.
And I,
I actually think you'd put that he,
you like him,
Tom Petty.
Same,
the same category.
All he needs is a better producer.
We got to hook him up with like what's that guys name?
Jimmy John with Dr Dre and that Jimmy I've been yes.
Right.
Cause that guy would say if he
would he be waiting because Jimmy Levine as m and m known it is the elevator.
You think he'd be like the problem is because he was great at pairing people up
with this guy who would go,
oh you need to bring with like that.
Right.
Like you should you and dre you get together.
Problem is this guy is too heavy for the elevator.
Yeah,
a little bit.
They said after haters.
Here's the thing,
the machine machine within.
Yeah,
the machine within.
It's kind of cat.
Here's it's,
I like it cause it's deep.
It's,
it could be kind of a catchy in punk industrial jam,
I don't know.
Needs help with the
loosening shoes with thin.
Yeah.
Shoes with this.
Machines with then and they got a gun.
Got a gun terminating their gun.
The terminator again.
Yeah.
Coming at Ya.
Here we go.
I'll sing it.
I got it.
Him and nick hoc.
Now that's an elevating Rapp Kinda guys,
right?
Yeah.
Both have lyrical talent.
Yup.
I see him like he should be with like rage against the machine or,
oh wow.
Now you're thinking like Jimmy.
Yeah.
Like I'd pair him with like that kind of a thing.
But we know how hard it is to compose music.
You remember Animal Song?
That's right.
And then what was yours called?
Um,
I did the butthole song.
Right.
It's hard.
And then you,
you did Kentucky.
Yeah,
I can talk he song.
those are,
yeah,
those weren't easy to make.
No.
Music is very difficult.
It takes a long time to make music.
Oh,
and I did the,
uh,
the,
should we bravo,
so I remember.
Yeah,
that was a good song.
Yeah.
Those are like,
those were really hard actually.
Yeah.
The animals.
My son,
my first hit.
See,
I can see what's wrong with it already.
I'm hearing I want to come in sooner.
Here we go.
What?
That's all I needed was this guy's lyric.
Well,
you need a producer.
Oh,
you're the,
you're the producer.
I just did.
I just made magic happens is elevated it by putting me together with this guy.
Damn,
dude,
that was awesome homie.
That's powerful.
That was pretty cool.
That's what I did.
Um,
let's see what I have a really tight,
this was my first song with you have a,
my,
if I got better with them,
hold,
hold.
Why do my ice cubes smell like a butthole?
The smell,
the smell.
It was like,
like really powerful.
It's kind of good
machining.
Something that actually fifth street bad.
Change what?
But we don't eat anything that smells like buttholes.
Wow.
See,
this is how magic happens right here.
She's just got to get the right people in the right room together at the right
time.
And that's how classics get made.
That's what's happening right now.
This says Charro ad.
It's sold here.
Mommy,
I'm in charge here.
I want you to listen to me.
Need to go to your mom's [inaudible] dot com and it's good,
but some of the new shut,
you need a new poster.
You know what I'm saying?
I got kids to fit.
Keep it in hundred.
He's got,
can we go?
Wow.
She wrote that copy and little aggressive.
She would just,
that's the great thing about,
or you can just be like,
read this.
Alright.
Oof.
Big words.
It's catchy
song.
Here we go.
Here we,
here we go.
Here we go.
Here we go again.
Here's my song.
Try and come back.
Catch.
You're trying to singing my song.
Here we go.
I kind of want like it machines with machines.
I sang my song.
Yeah.
I wish you could tell us the bt hears cause he has beaten.
It does.
That's what I'm saying.
There's some vision here,
but he needs a strong producer like you.
Yup.
Damn.
You're like the Jimmy Dean of the Juggalo world.
Yeah.
I feel like I could probably help this guy.
I wish we could have a talent show.
Yep.
And get these people
to another good thing around
hello
the shoes with shoes with too.
I don't know.
All right.
I've had enough of the machines with that one last part.
Say it again.
She is shaved with dad working on my song shaved with machines,
with death machines,
with den shoots,
with the hot,
the Halloween happy Halloween.
It's my favorite holiday.
You know,
he,
um,
I,
I really wish you would have played that earlier cause I feel like that was the,
that was a hook.
Like that was the hook I had to build up.
I like that.
Yeah.
Strong finish.
Anyway,
she's,
one of the things I'll be working on is my special shot.
I have things to work on now.
So passion products and projects,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
So this guy could be your opener when you DJ.
True.
Uh,
we have a couple of Dad boners I love dad.
Boners do you want a justified or unjustified one?
I like unjustified.
Unjustified.
Hmm.
Well,
I guess it's kind of a,
I guess technically this is justified because of why,
but it's still pretty entertaining machines where then machines with then
that justifies it.
Right.
Smoking Pot,
taking his drugs.
But
his reaction is pretty
Shanna's
forming some kind of thing and theirs
he's sees shadow,
isn't it?
Yes.
Shadows look like they're coming together.
This form,
the fucking trees growing out of them.
Holy Fuck.
No.
Through
few other tree shadows.
Fucking fig.
Yeah.
Drugs are good.
Yup.
You get that excited about shadows.
I mean,
you should be that excited about them,
I guess.
I mean,
he just smoked pot,
right?
Like that's all.
That was Salvia.
Oh,
push
right there.
Just hold it to hold it down.
It though.
I feel like if I had stayed in Hickory,
North Carolina,
we ended up like this guy.
Without a doubt.
Wait,
what does Salvia again,
I remember red banned smoking in a million a million years ago.
I thought you meant blue band.
No,
no,
not blue pants.
I didn't know that.
That's not,
what was that stuff like?
It's like some weird hallucinogenic,
isn't it?
Yeah.
And do some visions and oh my God.
No,
thank you.
Uh,
psychoactive plant.
No zags.
Yeah.
I'm for all that shit.
I just need a glass of wine and I'm like,
I'm seeing shadows.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
you know,
glass of Pinot.
Grigios all mom needs.
Okay.
Mom and dad.
Wow.
Hello.
But again,
I mean,
I don't know,
it was borderline on Justin.
It's justified because he's on drugs.
He's high.
But I mean you shouldn't be that excited about shadows.
No,
no,
no.
He's talking though.
Drugs will do that to you.
Drugs get you excited.
Here's a,
here's what I think.
It's a little different.
Uh,
Guitar,
Dad boner.
Anyway,
one of the lots is this Gibson,
USC Guitar Kiss.
No in the auction and it's hard to lock on it.
And that's apparently the reason that it was a mystery lot was because it,
it has a little parlor or the cardinal lit.
Oh so this guy bid auction.
Yeah,
mystery but on a mystery item.
Right.
And now he's like a bad teacher because it's like if this,
if this has what I think it has inside of it,
I'm a jack off right now.
Okay,
cool deposit pliers.
Cause it was quite flimsy lock and I've managed to em so twist it off my is to
force it.
Eventually it took us awhile to put 10
so now you've got the lock off of the guitar case and he's like,
does this or does this not have this amazing to champs?
Yeah.
Side of it.
Just hope that it is what exactly.
Just all,
oh wow.
Wow,
wow.
Wow.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
That's a red one is all looks a railroad.
Oh,
whoa.
Oh Wow.
Wow.
That's the biggest bargain I have ever,
ever hard.
Oh,
I love seeing someone that extent.
Yeah.
This one's making me happy.
Yeah,
like the Douche does.
The guy like doing Salvia at 40 in his backyard is kind of a bummer,
but you shadows
this guy is like genuinely stoked about something that matters.
I like that.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Oh,
oh,
oh
yeah.
Well the Trans Dorys the road tiles,
right?
Ooh,
sure.
I
did Fifo.
Woke us up at five in the morning with diarrhea and guy.
Cool.
Unreal.
What did he eat?
He ate everything that the baby drops,
you know?
Yeah.
Everything.
Spinach.
I just like,
it's not even good for them.
And the nine tasty and they love to eat everything that falls scrambled eggs,
chicken,
everything,
man.
Everything.
Just apple sauce and you look it up.
It's
bitsy.
So fat from eating toddler droppings.
It's really bad.
I know.
Fifo manner.
He hasn't had diarrhea in a minute.
So should we try giving top dog recall?
Yeah.
What?
What are we going to ask him about?
Anything and parking caught up in a while.
You know,
I love talking to him.
Yeah.
I miss him.
I know
he's supposed to come out.
Good
answer.
He's my favorite bad at answering.
Oh Hey.
Oh Dad,
buddy.
Hey,
what are you doing?
I'm driving back from seeing my brother.
Oh yeah.
How was it?
Oh,
it was great.
You know?
Yeah,
absolutely.
The same conversation every time I go out there.
Yeah.
Not In every case.
We say the same thing.
And then named Joe.
He's still a total animal.
Right.
We go to that.
What's that?
He's still a total animal.
Oh yeah.
He's told me he's build a soup.
All right.
He's off for lunch today.
Yeah.
How have your,
um,
uh,
and then how is,
how does driving,
like,
cause that's a good drive.
How does that affect your going to the bathroom?
Does that make you go more or less or how does it affect you?
Well,
you know,
I,
I made sure I left a whole job this morning to drive up.
You see em that I'd drop the load.
Yeah.
Which I did.
And then when I got up to visit him,
I dropped another luck.
Okay.
Yeah.
And then when we went to lunch,
I had a mini load so high,
I haven't had bombs away three times today.
And what I mean,
good.
Jake,
what kind of consistency though?
Well,
the,
the third one really was just to kind of a mini last year.
Then the first one was,
was okay.
And the second one was okay,
but it's important to buy.
I hit the road.
You're like seven 30 in the morning,
then I'm totally screwed up the day.
Oh really?
Yeah.
So,
uh,
are you drinking Mcdonald's coffee on your way?
You know,
home,
is that what you do?
You stop there and get a coffee?
Oh yeah.
I go to the drive to get a coffee and three Greens just landed three claims to
split
and not yet.
And that's your,
it's the best.
Right.
That's why he shitting so much,
mate.
I love it.
Yeah.
It's such good coffee,
but you shouldn't drink it off for you as you're driving.
Yeah,
I know.
That's probably gonna make you shit more.
Hey,
what did that,
you were at sea on a cruise when that horrific hurricane came through.
Um,
how was that,
what was that experience like being at sea during that?
Well,
because we,
um,
we were on the south side of Cuba and the storm was kind of coming through the
north side,
you know,
on the northeast side there.
I didn't like the ultimate,
you have a whole island in between,
so we didn't get a single wave.
Okay.
It was just calm as you can get.
My big concern was I parked my car on the ground floor.
Yeah.
In Miami,
the Miami,
of course,
I'm watching TV and I'm thinking,
and my car's going to get flooded.
I even called the insurance company from the shift just to,
you know,
may just to check the protocol and how do you,
well,
you're not going to believe.
And then I hear we can't get in Miami because there's a sunken sailboat.
Wait,
what did they tell you was the protocol?
It's a water comes up all of the rocker panel.
It's a total loss for them.
Oh Wow.
How were,
how was the cruise food wise and,
and,
you know,
dumping wise for you?
Oh,
the food was good.
And,
uh,
you know,
I was in my dorm routine there and uh,
basically,
you know,
you can't eat a little bit more.
Cruise ships have basically two or three a day,
I probably,
and they extended the crews
25 drops on the growth
kind of the whole week.
Wow.
Hey,
you got four x four extra days.
Would you,
would you be willing,
I found a seminar where they can teach you to orgasm from hugging someone.
Would you go to it if I sent you to it with mom?
You know,
I think that I probably,
uh,
little,
little past that point.
I mean there was a time when I was in high school that I can orgasm without
hugging anybody.
Okay.
Yeah.
But would you like to learn?
What'd you like to learn this tantric technique with mom?
That would be fun.
That would be really exciting.
Okay.
I'll have to explain to my butt and remains,
but you know,
you don't want her to think of some Indian religion,
you know what I mean?
Right.
I will.
Um,
I'll get all the details and send you guys and if you guys want to go,
it'll be all expenses paid.
Okay.
Oh Wow.
Wow.
So if you want to go,
okay.
Okay.
So we'll do some research.
You know,
you let us know if you want to go,
hey,
it's supposed to make money.
Yeah.
It's supposed to really,
you know,
thing.
So was just,
I'm just thinking about it,
but look,
I have to run.
I love you.
I'll call you in a little while.
Okay.
I'll give it love you.
Yeah.
I think he was more excited about the all expenses paid apart.
He was like,
damn good.
And then like,
I'll pay for it.
He's like,
wow,
that'd be neat.
Now is it in Florida?
I have no,
I mean I have no idea where.
I wonder where I will look it up and if they teach a thing,
I always say I would send them.
Yeah.
We just have to have a crew follow them around.
So funny.
Yeah.
I would love to see my folks reporting on that because like my dad be like,
it's kind of goofy and my mom would just be like,
hey,
still disclose.
This is so crazy.
So KCP disgusting,
disgusting.
Crazy.
Yeah.
I mean she was a little reticent to even buy a new bra with me.
Right.
You know,
let alone learn to come hug you don't.
Another thing we played during our live show,
but I'm just so obsessed with it,
is that guy's weird speech pattern.
He,
yeah,
he does.
He does youtube videos.
Yeah.
I can't get him out of my head.
This is the guy.
Texas has really been on my mind a lot lately and I wanted to go on your this
state in my own way with a countdown.
Respectfully dedicate this list to everyone who has been affected by Hurricane
Harvey.
All the inflections are wrong.
Maybe it's a computer are v I feel like it's a computer program talking.
No,
like a highly advanced when it sounds like right.
Here's another video taken one night showing a door pop open for no reason that
all this wasn't a regular door either.
It was a lock security and nobody was near.
I guess this could be a publicity stunt to drive visitors to the institute,
but I doubt they would disrespect native American culture by faking all of this.
Okay.
Do you think he talks like this to,
to people and conversation?
Did you think cause he's reading comp maybe.
Maybe the performing aspect.
Yeah.
Megan and I have been together for nearly three years.
Okay.
Yeah.
Ah,
it's hard to tell if they were truly pulled out by a ghost where someone was
just pushing other side of the shelf and playing a prank,
we'll never know for sure.
But it's,
it's like ups speak down,
speak,
you know what I mean?
Let's all combined.
I can't place where he's from either.
Know.
It's so bizarre.
Is it?
Is it just a,
Texas is hard.
Things were very bad.
They're never heard this,
this guy named his name is chills,
chills.
What's up?
Chills.
Let's see if he has,
if he has a bunch of stuff on there and not ever weird computer robot.
Yeah.
It's so weird.
I don't think that's it.
And so many people,
he does.
Remind me of the guy from,
uh,
married and dating,
the polyamory,
that fighter that you just played.
Yeah,
Megan.
Uh,
the vocal fry,
he has a similar,
I'm still a bit shaken up from what happened.
There's him,
I have no clue what I saw and they just want some answers explaining.
My family has managed to keep its hands on a good chuck of land out in the
middle of Ochoco national forest for us.
It's a beautiful place down there.
There's no cell service,
no paved roads.
And the closest person to us is miles away.
So it's a person talking like 611,000 subscribers on his youtube channel.
It must be the cadence you're wrapping people in.
Yeah,
cause I'm intrigued and I,
I'd like to see his face.
I wonder why he's not showing his identity.
Sweet.
Hmm.
Is that add on that.
Sorry.
Um,
yeah.
I don't know.
Let's see.
To the face reveal,
I wanted to talk to you about the new channel I'm launching called game be
posting photos of myself through my personal account on Instagram.
Please add me on both platforms if you want to stay connected.
My dms are open if you have any questions or suggestions,
so less suggestions,
suggestions.
How's it going guys?
Marvelous makey here and I am pleased to announce that I am actually the winner
of the raffle top 15 I guess he keeps his,
he keeps his face concealed for,
I dunno what I'm going to keep it intriguing.
People don't know is
we should do that.
Where are you from?
Why do you talk like that?
Please let us know.
Chills,
make a video where you go.
The reason that I talk like this is that my family,
when we saw it goes,
says a kid who goes with talks to us in a higher language,
then you can process in your brain.
And it affected the way that my English speaking skills develop.
Yes,
exactly.
How he talks gene.
Yeah.
Emailed that.
Right.
They're pretty wild.
Um,
all right Jean,
anything else?
No.
All right.
Yeah.
Love you.
Please go to your mom's house,
podcast.com please go to [inaudible] dot com for tickets.
Please go to our store merchant.
Got Mud.
Watch my Netflix special to mother inferior.
And if you go to Christina p online,
um,
I have a store.
Yeah.
Emerge story.
She has new new product shit.
I even met him.
Yeah,
it's helping a that's that's related to the special.
That's right.
So I've got some shirts that,
uh,
that I designed.
We designed these people and that's merchant method.com/christina.
It's on Christina on line.
There's a tab there.
All right,
so cool.
Check it out guys.
I got some Shites I got a special,
there you go.
Very exciting.
Thank you guys.
We'll see you next time.
Bye Jean.
He's in pain,
Babe.
It's not funny.
His legs are broken.
Can't stand.
He's collapsing because as much as are broken it.
Ooh.
Screaming,
screaming,
canceled.
What's up?
Yeah.
Screaming.
Yay.
Bryce.
You'd be time left.
Side.
Left side.